let's take a look at more examples of
using the freemium model remember that
users are more likely to download the
free app compared to a priced one there
are numbers a way to monetize free apps
by using in-app billing yeah there's
actually two avenues that you can take
there are objects that users can
purchase once and they're always able to
access so example something like levels
Telltale Games Angry Birds all allow
users to unlock new levels by paying for
it there's also objects that users will
always need to keep purchasing coins
extra lives boosters gems whatever clash
of clans is an example of this in this
model the goal is to gain trust we want
to lower the entry barrier and allow
users to try us and fall in love after
that we can offer users who are using
the product to pay for it and they will
be willing to do it with a big smile if
we are doing everything correctly
because users will recognize the value
that we created for them